bien
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este
su magazine 100% dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares
el primer ministro de sudán abdalá hand
ok vuelve al poder tras ser liberado de
su arresto domiciliario en el cual
permanecía desde el golpe de estado del
pasado 25 de octubre su regreso se da
tras un acuerdo firmado con el líder
militar y que contempla la liberación de
todos los detenidos durante la toma pero
el pacto es rechazado por varios
sectores
libia se prepara para las que serían sus
primeras elecciones presidenciales desde
su independencia en 1951 a un mes de los
comicios varias candidaturas han
desatado tensiones entre ellas las del
hijo del fallecido dictador muamar al
gadafi y la del polémico mariscal jalifa
haftar ambos acusados de crímenes de
guerra
los guepardos son los felinos más
rápidos del mundo y cada día corren
hacia la extinción cada año 300
cachorros de esta especie se trafican a
través de somalilandia para adinerados
compradores de medio oriente que buscan
mascotas exóticas los que logran
sobrevivir pueden alcanzar hasta 15 mil
dólares en el mercado ilegal
empezamos en sudán porque el derrocado
primer ministro abdalá hanbok vuelve al
poder tras ser liberado después del
golpe de estado del 25 de octubre andoc
junto al líder de la junta militar abdel
fattah al burhan firmaron un acuerdo que
contempla su regreso y busca poner fin a
la crisis también plantea la liberación
de todos los detenidos desde la toma
castrense sin embargo no todos los
involucrados en la transición están de
acuerdo con lo refrendado en jartúm y
piden continuar con las protestas rafael
pérez nos trae los detalles
un nuevo acuerdo para poner fin a la
crisis en sudán
el nuevo pacto alcanzado entre civiles y
la junta militar estipula el retorno del
primer ministro abdalá hang dog a su
cargo cuando se había mantenido en
arresto domiciliario desde que fue
derrocado el 25 de octubre nosotros
hemos vivido una crisis durante mucho
tiempo gracias a dios hoy estamos
orgullosos de que con la firma de este
decreto político podamos sentar una base
real para nuestro periodo de transición
como lo imaginamos y como el pueblo de
sudán no quería el comienzo de la
transición el pacto contempla además la
formación de un gobierno de tecnócratas
durante el periodo de transición la
liberación de todos los presos políticos
y estipula que la declaración
constitucional de 2019 alcanzará tras la
salida de omar al bachir será la base
para el cambio político a célestin
este acuerdo ayuda a liberar la asfixia
esperamos la asfixia interna externa y a
volver a la senda de la transición para
lograr una democracia duradera en
nuestro país
sin embargo lo pactado no alivió las
pensiones en las calles miles de
personas marcharon hacia el palacio
presidencial tras el anuncio del acuerdo
acusando al primer ministro de haber
vendido la revolución las
manifestaciones fueron dispersadas con
gases lacrimógenos
la coalición civil que había compartido
el poder con los militares antes del
golpe dijo que no reconoce el acuerdo y
la asociación de profesionales sudaneses
también se opuso el acuerdo traicionero
firmado hoy entre hanbok y al burham es
totalmente rechazado y sólo concierne a
sus partidos los civiles se rechazan la
presencia de los militares en la
política sudanesa y exigen rendición de
cuentas ante la justicia para los
responsables de la toma militar se
estima que cerca de 40 personas murieron
en medio de la represión de las
protestas ciudadanas desde el 25 de
octubre
libia se prepara para sus primeras
elecciones presidenciales desde su
independencia en 1951 previstas para el
próximo 24 de diciembre y varias de las
candidaturas tensan los comicios
destinados a poner fin a un país
dividido por la guerra entre los
aspirantes se encuentra el hijo del
fallecido dictador muamar al gadafi y
también el polémico mariscal jalifa
haftar ambos acusados de crímenes de
guerra
más de 20 candidatos buscan la
presidencia de libia pero no es la
cantidad lo que complican sus comicios
sino las figuras que pretenden llegar a
dirigir el país devastado por años de
guerra civil
entre ellos saif al islam gadafi hijo
del fallecido dictador libio muamar al
gadafi y también el mariscal jalifa
haftar una de las figuras más
controvertidas en el conflicto noble lo
que ha despertado malestar en la
población
ya estamos en contra de que criminales
de guerra sean candidatos con derecho a
cualquier cosa para las elecciones o
para cargos gobernar
sánchez javi aus 6 en seis semanas
afecta aula ambos son acusados de
crímenes de guerra mientras gadafi es
buscado por la corte penal internacional
por su papel durante las revueltas que
derrocaron a su padre en 2011 haftar es
despreciado por su ofensiva militar
contra el gobierno de acuerdo nacional
apoyado por la onu que buscaba
establecer la paz en el país
se debe establecer la ley electoral
especialmente las condiciones para la
candidatura de modo que no haya lugar en
libia para quien haya cometido un crimen
contra el pueblo libio no haya lugar
para ninguna persona que haya asesinado
robado o malversado estas personas no
pueden asegurar un lugar a expensas del
pueblo libio
destinadas a realizarse el próximo 24 de
diciembre estas serían las primeras
elecciones presidenciales en libia desde
su independencia en 1951 y con las que
se busca volver a unir a un país que
está dividido por dos gobiernos luego
del caos generado por las revueltas de
2011 que pusieron fin al mandato de 42
años de moamar el gadafi en brazaville
la capital del congo una clínica creada
en 2013 se especializó en el tratamiento
de los problemas de salud
específicamente de piel de personas con
albinismo este proyecto que ha podido
contar con las facilidades de las
autoridades gubernamentales para su
instalación representa una oportunidad
única para una población a menudo
marginada y discriminada desde enero se
lleva a cabo una campaña especial de
tratamiento contra el cáncer de piel los
detalles en el siguiente informe
en el corazón de braza común la capital
del combo los albinos tiene la
oportunidad de cuidar su piel médicos y
especialistas de rusia lanzaron una
campaña de detección y tratamiento del
cáncer de piel en la clínica de la
asociación de albinos johnny sounds en
común con ser la busque el apoyo el
cáncer de piel es la primera causa de
muerte de las personas con albinismo
hasta ahora hemos tratado a más de 468
personas
para que esto sea posible hemos traído
expertos de rusia especialistas en
albinismo no sólo para tratar sino
también para formar a los medios
gemma mujer de 31 años que padece
infecciones en la cara y el cuello tiene
grandes esperanzas en esta campaña
estoy esperando que mejoren las heridas
y en general estoy esperando otra imagen
de los albinos porque la mayoría de los
albinos tienen manchas y la cara muy
dañada el albinismo es una enfermedad
genética rara hereditaria pero no
contagiosa que provoca un déficit
en la producción de melanina lo que
lleva a una ausencia total o parcial de
pigmento en la piel el cabello y los
ojos a menudo en áfrica los albinos no
pueden permitirse unas gafas de sol
eficaces o una protección solar
las personas que sufren esta condición
suelen además ser discriminadas atacadas
e incluso sacrificadas en oscuros
delitos de brujería que
un albino no es una persona enferma o
algo así un albino es como cualquier
otro ser humano es solo la diferencia en
la piel
según la onu en algunas partes del mundo
cerca del 90% de los albinos mueren
entre los 30 y los 40 años
vamos ahora a somalilandia en el cuerno
de áfrica en esta república otro
proclamada sin reconocimiento
internacional se convirtió en una zona
de tránsito donde cada año cientos de
cachorros de guepardo salen de
contrabando hacia los estados del golfo
para ser vendidos como mascotas
esto genera preocupación por el futuro
de una especie amenazada por la pérdida
de su hábitat informe de jamal benomar
él es gris tiene unas semanas de vida
apenas y pesa 7 sientes gramos son los
otros cachorros de guepardo acaba de ser
rescatado escapando así de un creciente
comercio ilegal en somalilandia
este pequeño cachorro green estaba en un
mal estado los otros tres estaban más o
menos bien pero generalmente están
desnutridos son tan pequeños que tardan
un poco al morir pero greene y sus
compañeros tuvieron suerte se estima que
unos 300 cachorros arrebatados a sus
madres pasan cada año por su bailan ya
para ser vendidos en los estados del
golfo al igual que los autos de valor y
los fajos de billetes los que pardos son
exhibidos en self y por sus propietarios
como signo de riqueza el precio de uno
puede alcanzar hasta 15 mil dólares en
el mercado ilegal y la gente que ve tus
fotos o tu vídeo piensa mucho también
quiero tenido y malasia pero no consigue
un perro o un gato y cuidarlos pero los
animales salvajes deben vivir en la
natural
este comercio es devastador para el
felino más amenazado de áfrica hasta
provocar la extinción de la especie
emerge custión alejados de su entorno
los guepardos rescatados no podrán
sobrevivir por sí mismos en la
naturaleza y acabarán reubicados en un
recinto natural en las afueras de la
capital hace un siglo había unos 100.000
de estos felinos en el mundo hoy apenas
quedan 7000 después de venir etiopía
celebró el regreso a su suelo de una
serie de antiguos tesoros saqueados en
el siglo 19 por soldados británicos la
colección de artefactos fue devuelta por
reino unido bélgica y países bajos tras
una larga campaña diplomática para su
restitución ésta incluye una corona un
escudo imperial copas de plata un libro
de oraciones manuscrito y varias joyas
los tesoros fueron representados o
presentados a la prensa en el museo
nacional de addis abeba dos meses
después de su entrega oficial a las
autoridades etíopes en septiembre en
londres su regreso a etiopía se da en
medio de un llamado de los países
africanos a occidente para vuelvan los
botines coloniales
vamos a marruecos un equipo
internacional de arqueólogos descubrió
la joyería más antigua del mundo una
serie de perlas de concha que tienen por
lo menos 150.000 años de antigüedad y
que se cree fueron utilizadas como
alguna forma de comunicación no verbal
unas perlas que han atravesado los
milenios un grupo de arqueólogos
descubrió 30 perlas de concha en
marruecos coloreados con ocre y rojo
estos juegos de joyas se consideran los
más antiguos de la historia de la
humanidad
la edad de estas conchas es actualmente
de 150 mil años lo que significa que son
las más antiguas conocidas en el mundo
las piezas fueron encontradas hace unas
semanas en la cueva de abismo a 15
kilómetros de la ciudad de esauira el
equipo internacional de investigadores
trabajó de la mano del gobierno marroquí
tenemos el honor y la oportunidad de
presentar este descubrimiento es por
supuesto un descubrimiento importante
para marruecos pero también para la
humanidad porque pone en tela de juicio
la historia de la humanidad
estamos yendo 150 mil años atrás cuando
las civilizaciones nos dejaron un
patrimonio que hoy está descubierto por
nuestros arqueólogos y por tanto se
encuentra en la historia que estamos
descubriendo la misma especie de concha
se ha encontrado en joyas de épocas
posteriores en todo el continente
africano según los investigadores estas
joyas fueron utilizadas entre miembros
de diferentes grupos para comunicarse
entre ellos
y finalizamos en nigeria con la
exposición del artista franco-camerunés
fred ebb a mí quien llega para mostrar
su obra por primera vez en lagos la
capital comercial y cultural de la
nación más poblada de áfrica
influenciado por los grandes nombres del
pop art un movimiento ha nacido a
finales de los años 50 en reino unido y
eeuu evans y muestra sus coloridos
retratos dibujados digitalmente en ellos
o bien de homenajea y con los africanos
y afroamericanos como la cantante nina
simone la leyenda del boxeo mohamed alí
o la activista angela davis con estas
imágenes despedimos este capítulo de
áfrica siete días recuerda que si
quieres repetir esta u otra emisión lo
puede hacer a través de nuestra página
web www punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]